all right here we go all within my hands  metallica this is avi by the way good  morning avi  hey hi i always say hi to howard hey  what's going on with robbie hey  what are you up to i'm just getting a  lot shorter  what are you doing he works here  hanging with metallica singing backup  vocals awesome  it's a big deal don't [ __ ] up  too late well it's our job all right  here is metallica with avi  [Music]  all within my hands  squeeze it in crush it down  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  love is controlled  [Music]  i'll die if i let go  [Music]  again  [Music]  [Music]  oh  myself myself  [Music]  love is controlled  die if i let go  [Music]  is  [Music]  him  [Music]  again  [Music]  i will only let you breathe  [Music]  [Music]  now  [Music]  [Music]  now  is  crush it down  all  [Music]  beware  love is  [Music]  boy is that beautiful boys metallica  featuring avi